here with the very latest breaking news
coverage he's on the ground he's in
Israel he's been doing a phenomenal job
it's 4:06 a.m. his time is our friend
and and our host of America reports John
Roberts John great reporting all week
thank you for staying up so early in the
morning for us oh Sean not a problem uh
we like to burn the Midnight Oil around
here war never stops neither do we but
let me start with what you mentioned
just a moment ago and that was who was
responsible for this attack on the
hospital in Gaza the chief IDF spokesman
Israeli Defense Force spokesman held a
briefing around midnight in which he
said that Israel has got Drone footage
has got Communications intercepts and
radar data that Pro that it was an
Islamic Jihad rocket that malfunctioned
in mid-flight and crashed down on top of
that hospital killing all of those
people he said that that information
will be put together in a comprehensive
brief to be presented to President Biden
when he gets here for his meeting with
with prime minister Netanyahu a little
bit later on this morning now no
question though that this Hospital
explosion has complicated this entire
trip uh you mentioned the fact that the
Arab leaders of Jordan and Egypt have
canceled a quad Summit that was also
going to include the Palestinian leader
mmud abas that was scheduled for Jordan
after the president departs Israel John
Kirby on Air Force One on the way over
here Sean trying to put the best face on
that saying that it wasn't cancelled
because those nations were out Ed over
what was happening and what happened at
that hospital it was canceled because of
3 days of mourning now Kirby also said
that the president is going to have some
tough questions for Israel luckily about
the hospital which Israel plans to
counter with this evidence that it says
it is gathered but also about what the
aims and the strategy of potential
ground operation are and very
importantly to President Biden how to
ensure the rank and file Palestinians
who have nothing to do with Hamas are
are given as much safety as possible and
also as much Aid as can possibly be
brought in to the southern area of the
country while an Israeli ground
operation goes at Hamas in the northern
part also complicating all of this and
you mentioned Hezbollah is what will
happen tomorrow because Hasa has
declared tomorrow will be a day of quote
unprecedented anger there have been
skirmishes that we've been reporting
across the northern border of Israel uh
in into Lebanon on going back and forth
with Hezbollah firing anti-tank missiles
Israel responding will Hezbollah step up
those attacks could the war begin to
widen there's no indication that hasran
nasala who is the leader of Hezbollah
has gotten his marching orders from Iran
yet so maybe things will remain at the
low level that they've been for the past
10 days between Hezbollah and Israel one
other point Sean that we should uh pass
along to you as well is that President
Biden according to John Kirby is going
to take some time after his meeting with
Netanyahu and he will meet uh with the
families of Americans who were killed in
that horrific attack on Saturday October
the 7th as well as the families of
Americans who believe that their loved
ones are being held hostage big day
ahead of a Sean John if I may ask you
the the cancellation of meetings with
the the leaders of Jordan and Egypt and
and uh fat president abas the
Palestinian president uh how is that
being interpreted if I may ask on the
ground I I think it's probably part of
the universal condemnation of what was
initially believed to have been an
Israeli air strike uh none of the Arab
Nations have dialed back on that even
the United Nations came right out and
blamed Israel for the air strike so it
we'll see tomorrow how powerful the
evidence is that the IDF puts out there
but if they can coordinate Drone footage
now let me just say that we have seen
some video footage that was taken by a
news organization that does show a
rocket malfunctioning in mid-flight and
then an explosion occurring on the
ground shortly after but if the Israeli
Defense Force can come up with
compelling evidence uh through radar
through drones and again they've got
them flying all over and these
communications intercepts which are said
to be between militants who are blaming
Islamic Jihad for this they may be able
to make a compelling case that it wasn't
Israel that was responsible but Arab
Nations likely wouldn't even accept it
if if it was right there in front of
them for everybody to see all right John
Roberts again thanks for staying up so
late for us hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else